is a kind of do's and don'ts in this new
classroom setup and if we zoom in on it
the traditional education practice would
be classroom experiences or assignments
and assessments that are built from an
individualist perspective that's the
don't the the new way to do it the
equity principle is to shift to a
collectivism perspective to engage
authentic lived experiences and relate
to students cultural norms
what are you going to do Bill to shift
from the individualist perspective to
the collectivism perspective in your
Chemistry classes in this semester
nothing I'm not going to do it
fair enough
I'm
I'm just not going to comply
um I'm going to teach chemistry the way
I always have I'm going to teach
chemistry in the way that is the most
logical way to get the information and
the skill set into my students
I teach students I teach freshman level
chemistry for science majors and these
are people who want to go to medical
school and they want to go to pharmacy
school and I also teach introchem
for students that want to become nurses
and other Allied health professionals
and their skills that they need to bring
from my classroom such as dosage
calculation
that they need to carry on if they don't
get anywhere else and particularly in
the in the the
students that want to go to nursing
school
and one of the things about some a
discipline like chemistry is
as well as math and physics is that it's
one of the best places to learn to think
critically and logically and problem
solve
and that's what I'm concerned about I'm
not concerned about collectivism
um
and
I do evaluate my students on an
individual basis and so if anything I
I'm I am
strongly individualistic because
my students get the grades that come
from their own personal work
you know so always
are we to collectivize grades so
everybody you know gets a CE now or a c
minus do you feel that um these Dei
standards are compelling you to express
ideas that you don't agree with and if
so in what way
uh definitely and I think it's beyond
even what I agree with personally or not
it's it's a waste of classroom time
we have a limited amount of time that we
need to get through a lot of material
every class period whether it's lecture
in the lab
and
I think in The Sciences is it's
particularly inappropriate because
um
you know there's a quote that's
attributed to me what is the Dei
anti-racist perspective on the atomic
mass of of boron and and that really
lays it out because
um science Should Have No Agenda other
than you know Relentless pursuit of the
truth
and wherever that leads and with Dei
we're expected to
search out racism within you know
science curriculum Etc and it's just not
there
so
um yeah it really interferes it's going
to interfere with um with classroom
instruction as well as laboratory work
yeah I'm really curious here what
exactly do they expect you to do in
order to infuse your teaching with Dei
like I'm very curious like do you have
colleagues in The Sciences who are on
board with this I'm like how do they
anticipate doing this it seems
contrary to my understanding of what one
typically learns in a chemistry class
well I honestly think Liz that
um my colleagues many of them are just
going to go along and and I'm just going
to be very Frank here give lip service
and
um they'll in the in the evaluation
process that's where this really comes
down as a tenured faculty member all of
my colleagues are also tenured
um
when we get evaluated we have a
self-evaluation and there's also
classroom observation from our Dean and
a faculty peer and
the self-evaluation is where there's a
lot of questions about you know what are
we going to be doing or what have we
done
um to promote anti-racism and Dei
a ideologies which is really what it is
it's an ideology and so
um I think many of them in fact I've
actually now that I think about it have
been told recently since the lawsuit was
filed that they appreciate what we're
doing because
you know they're they're kind of too
afraid to stick their neck out and
they're just going to go along and give
lip service to you know we do this this
and this but I think some of them are
not aware that if they say that they
treat all students the same that's
considered a racist statement and and
thought process by the people who have
put together
um the Dei a you know I'll call
standards here in California it's not
enough to say I treat all this all my
students the same
that's not enough that's not going far
enough so
um I don't know there's only four of us
total where I teach and I haven't had a
lot of contact since the lawsuit was
filed with uh my colleagues at the other
sister campuses
but um I'm sure that there are some in
fact you know now now that my memory got
jogged again I know that there are
faculty who essentially have removed all
reference
to any scientist or you know physicist
who happens to be white and and
I think that is just
not helpful to the discipline this is
the mechanism for enforcement is I guess
you go to your annual review and that is
one of the metrics your judge judged
upon and it seems like even even tenure
is in in play here so uh what is it that
how is it that you expect
this to play out once let's say that
this law were to remain in effect or
this regulation were to remain in effect
how would that play out come annual
review time what how would the way that
your performance is evaluated do you
think would be different than it has
been in the past
uh yeah that's a good question
um let me go back to something you said
at the beginning this definitely is top
down I don't know a single faculty
member that
um
in in all the discussions in in the
entire 15 plus years I've been where I'm
at that at read the college that that
wants this in terms of auras as you said
clamoring for this I don't know a single
faculty member that
um personally now I'm I'm sure there are
progressives on the campus that
um when what happened in 2020 I know
they went all in
um
but I have not had a single discussion
with anybody
in The Sciences at least that
where I'm at that wants that wants this
that is asking for this this is 100 top
down that is that is a great
characterization now as far as my
performance evaluation well again we we
call it an evaluation
and now that I'm since I'm tenured
it's every three years now this this
affects me but it really is going to
affect new hires they're evaluated every
year
and
I want to make everybody aware of
something else that's happening right
now and that is they have changed and
what I mean by they is it's a community
college system of California and our
camp our district has made it very clear
that we are to change hiring practices
and and who gets interviews and who
ultimately gets hired
um it has been 100 influenced by the the
deia ideology
and so that is happening right now as
well so back to my evaluation
I'm supposed to be evaluated next spring
and it's a look back it is what am I
doing this semester what did I do
meaning fall what did I do the previous
two years and now that they have this
new these these new questions in the
rubric what did I do to you know forward
anti-racist principles and what did I do
to basically forward deia principles I
don't know the exact question off the
top of my head but that's that's the the
Crux of it is that they're going to look
back and as far as is my tenure at risk
I to be very Frank I don't know why it
wouldn't be because it all depends on
who is going to be evaluating
my responses to those questions
um what I anticipate now I'm just giving
my opinion I don't have any
um proof of this I haven't received some
document that said that this is what's
going to happen but just in my
experience in how things typically go
um what I'm anticipating is that if we
give an answer I give an answer that
they don't find appropriate there's
discussion about this and then HR will
say well why don't you undergo a little
bit of additional bias training why
don't you undergo some training to
actually show you how to be an
anti-racist bill that's what I would
anticipate happening and it's to me it's
a struggle session we're going to have
to have I'm going to have a little
struggle session
and um
perhaps you know again I'm just giving
my opinion this may be seeming like from
left field but
um that's how this kind of stuff goes is
that well you're gonna you're gonna go
to training until your mind is right hey
thanks for watching that clip from our
conversation with Jesse Appleby of fire
and Professor bill blanken from Reedley
College for the full conversation click
here for another clip go here